it looks like both China and we in the
United States are looking at each other
now
with the darkest interpretation of each
other's motives
um
how could we change this so this this if
we persist on that path it this could
turn out badly Ray first your thoughts
and then Henry
um I I think that in both countries
there's a recognition that the um
whoever you're speaking with might
change and the policies might change and
so it's almost like uh the prisoner's
dilemma
um you know if you don't know whether
the other side is going to kill you or
or should you cooperate should you kill
the other side or should you cooperate
and the answer is kill the other side
for the defensiveness and there's a bit
of that going on and so I think that
what has to be done is the placing of
um the um those risks as the Paramount
importance and the establishment of
clear red lines and the understanding of
not how to negotiate those red lines
um so that they build around
um that the fact that there could be all
sorts of competitions and so on but you
do not want to cross certain red lines
and so if it becomes a Paramount
importance I don't feel that just
finding ways to cooperate like there's
climate change and so on that can change
the mood and it certainly can but I
think you have to deal with the
existential risks that come from as
perceived by each country and then also
then the greatest existential risk of
those two fighting and you've got to
make that a number one objective I would
presume you know Henry your thoughts
this sounds very very much what you
would say too but your thoughts on this
my thought is uh very parallel to to
this uh
the two sides to the Dilemma both sides
have it's that if they engage in their
traditional Arms Control exchanges
it can be used as a sort of sort of
intelligence rather than as an element
of restraint that they learn about each
other's capacities but do not do about
the needs for the strange or the
definition of limits so that we first
step would have to be that it will
scientifically the tips is a principle
objective to define the red lines
which would Define limits and to define
the methods of competition Beyond which
one does not go
in the uh technological field that
requires
a reorientation of strategic thinking
on outside and probably on this on the
Chinese side but no such dialogue exists
today
and not even the beginnings of it
and
I obsessively keep saying
we have this Paradox we have to be
strong we cannot be we cannot fall
behind
but we cannot in that process
forget that if the other side
thinks the same way if red lines do not
exist a catastrophic outcome becomes
very possible and that should be the
first step to avoid